another thing Dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation Dr bright  scp-682 is not a wondertainment product  Dr wondertainment has produced plenty of  strange and unusual products over the  years from Custom pets to household  robots to the mysterious little misters  but one thing the anomalous toy company  has never made is a giant hateful  reptile that needs to be submerged in  acid at all times so it doesn't kill  everything in sight so we would like to  advise Dr bride to stop looking for a  wondertainment logo on scp-682's upper  palette as well as on its posterior  stomach or the bottom of its foot that's  a pretty good way to get yourself eaten  alive